- Have you, have y'all met before?
(crowd cheering and clapping)
- No, but (laughing)
- We haven't...
- I have this thing where I
have amnesia with famous people.
So I...
- We may well of that we
have actually (laughs).
- I, well we might have met,
and if I see you again...
- Wait, have y'all met?
- [Eddie Redmayne] No...
- [Emily Deschanel] No.
- I don't really...
(Kelly claps and laughs)
but I'm so thrilled to
hear that you have amnesia,
'cause I have, like, a brain like a sieve.
And so I have exactly the same thing
and it's horrendously offensive
to people who I've actually met.
(Emily laughs)
- I know people get very
offended when you don't remember.
And it's like, Oh my God,
there's so many people in the world.
I'm so sorry.
(Eddie and audience laughs)
- It's, I, I think I have
like this thing where I
hold people up to this.
I, I, I met Seth Rogen and I was like,
"So nice to meet you."
And he's like, "Well, we've met before."
And I was like...
- Oh.
- Oh, really?
And he's like, "Yeah, remember we met
at the audition for '40-Year-Old Virgin'?"
And I was like, "No, nope."
(Eddie and audience laughs)
"I didn't audition for that.
I don't know what you're talking about."
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And then, like three weeks
later I was like, "I did."
(Eddie laughs)
"I did audition for that movie."
(Kelly and audience laughs)
And it's happened several times,
but I've been savvier and just been like,
"Yes..."
- Amazing.
- "It's so nice to see you again."
- Exactly, "To see you."
- See you.
To...
- [Emily And Kelly} See you.
It was very helpful, "Lovely to see you."
(Emily laughing)
- Anyway. But I don't ever get offended.
If you don't remember this
moment, I will just...
- [Emily Deschanel] I think...
- Not care.
- [Emily] I think I will.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah. I'll be like, "Cool, me neither."